Então o conceito de fundamentalista está essencialmente ligado a
o conceito de medição na mecânica quântica
antes da mecânica quântica ser desenvolvida
havia um conhecimento geral
por parte dos cientistas de que se você tem um sistema que está
num determinado estado
e você faz uma medição nele, vai obter
um resultado bem definido
na mecânica quântica isso não é mais o caso, você pode ter
um sistema que está num estado perfeitamente bem definido
e ainda assim quando você faz certas
medições nele, pode obter resultados aleatórios
então para eu ilustrar esse conceito melhor
preciso trazer o conceito de superposição
superposição é um conceito que não é intuitivo
é baseado num sistema que exibe
várias combinações lineares de estados ao
mesmo tempo, e você pode pensar nisso
como por exemplo uma onda de rádio carregando
muitas frequências diferentes, não há nada
de incomum nisso
o que dá o sabor quântico à superposição é o fato
de medir o sistema
então vou ilustrar com um exemplo
imagine que você tem um sistema de setas
e você prepara o sistema
de modo que todas as setas apontem para a esquerda
e então você vai e
faz a pergunta ao sistema: você está para cima ou para baixo?
e pergunta a cada seta, pois como as setas apontam para a esquerda, podem ser
expressas e descritas
como uma superposição linear entre
cima e baixo, você vai obter
resultados de cinquenta por cento para cima
e cinquenta por cento quando você faz a pergunta: você está para cima?
você obtém esse resultado do sistema
e então você pode preparar um
estado diferente do sistema onde metade
das setas aponta para cima e a outra metade
aponta para baixo e você faz a mesma pergunta
e obtém o mesmo resultado
são dois sistemas muito diferentes
e você perdeu essa informação
por um bom tempo agora
como você pode determinar qual é a diferença?
os sistemas são muito diferentes
porque no primeiro caso você preparou o sistema em
um estado puro, e há uma pergunta que você
pode fazer ao sistema que vai te dar uma resposta determinística
e não aleatória, e essa pergunta é: você está à esquerda ou à direita?
vai te dizer cem por cento que estão à esquerda
no segundo caso não há pergunta que você possa fazer
que te dê cem por cento determinístico, porque é uma mistura
resolve isso porque é uma mistura
então se você perguntar esquerda ou direita
vai ser aleatório porque metade está para cima
e metade para baixo, se você perguntar cima ou baixo
a mesma coisa, vai ser cinquenta por cento
como isso se relaciona com a aleatoriedade quântica?
então você pode imaginar que isso é
semelhante a jogar uma moeda, vai ser cara ou coroa
mas não é como jogar uma moeda de verdade
porque quando você joga, é porque
a única razão pela qual você não sabe o resultado que vai obter
é porque você não conhece
a energia com que jogou a moeda, o ângulo, o momento e
as condições ambientais na sala
e assim por diante, então se você soubesse tudo isso
poderia prever cara ou coroa, são
variáveis que estão ocultas para o observador
e por muitos anos os cientistas pensaram que havia
variáveis similares na mecânica quântica que
se revelariam como aleatoriedade
e não foi até o
trabalho seminal de John Bell nos anos sessenta que foi
demonstrado que não é esse o caso
e agora todo físico
reconhece que não há nenhuma
teoria de variáveis ocultas que seja compatível com a mecânica quântica
então é realmente verdade que quando você mede um sistema
a natureza revela a partir do
não importa quanto tempo eu pense nisso, eu
ainda acho incrível